most people can't get out of posting the
same over and over cuz they need
the same results even though it's
declining attention is the number one
asset Gary taught you a trick a few
weeks ago and immediately you got like
600,000 I don't even know the number
600,000 likes or something this makes me
so happy this was like two weeks ago and
it's like I this feels like very
gratifying to me it's like instant
validation to giving good strategy it's
not even a trick tag me in the
screenshot and he was like look 2.6
million views 18 million views 12
million views it was the same week that
you told him underpriced attention
Arbitrage the opportunity you kicked off
that uh front space still photo with the
text and then the video that follows
genius yeah it's funny for everybody to
give it Clarity Instagram's tougher now
supply and demand not like it was when
we were kicking in 2014 and a lot of the
demand went to Tik Tok and YouTube
shorts but the supply is super up
yesterday more people posted on
Instagram than ever before so it gets
harder so you're looking for what I call
Strategic organic content what's the
organic content
move